my name is Jocelyn power aka horse power
I'm a rapper and comedian from Vancouver
but most importantly I love curry now
I'm living in New York City and
realizing just how little I know from
Japan to Jamaica to the Philippines
every culture has its own take on a dish
I grew up eating with my Punjabi family
get ready this is gonna be good are you
ready for the big reveal I was born
hungry all aboard the Bicol Express is
coming from India and it's got shrimp in
it
Indian cooking is like jazz it's a
little bit of this a little bit of that
but when it's all put on one plate when
it works all together big one - I'm
scared now I'm the one nervous about the
ghost pepper here we go
whatever you want to call curry we know
it's awesome because it's a fusion of
different spices and stories and love
the food is always there the dog is
always there through the food food is
love sure I'm on a mission and I'm
meeting up with some friends to help me
explore one of the world's most
misunderstood meals we're here we're
hungry and we're eating our way through
the five boroughs welcome to the curry
shop
[Music]
you're paying for dinner your pillow
thank you baby I believe you got I
thought I was having dinner with you